وسط هموم السودان تبرز معضله للدول
الراغبه في اجلاء مواطنيها وخاصه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
تجربه افغانستان لا يمكن ان تعاد بالنسبه
لواشنطن كان الاجلاء من مطار كابول ممكنا
كونه تحت السيطره الامريكيه اما في
السودان فالوضع مختلف
حال المطارات هنا لا يساعد مطار الخرطوم
تحت القصف المستمر وباقي المطارات لا تخلو
من المشكلات وربما هذا ما دفع البيت
الابيض للاقرار بالحقيقه
تجربه نقل الدبلوماسيين باعدادهم المحدوده
كانت ممكنه لكن الطريقه ذاته لم يكن ممهدا
امام نقل مدنيين متفرقين باعداد هائله وسط
هدى لا سلام فيها فلا اخلاء دون وقف طويل
لاطلاق النار لضمان سلامه المدنيين خطه
نقل جماعي برا هذا ما تدرسه وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه لنقل مواطنيها من الخرطوم فبعد
قصف متبادل لا ينقطع في محيط المطارات
تستخدم امريكا قدراتها الاستخباراتيه في
مراقبه الطرق وتوقع التهديدات الناجمه عن
اجلاء بري محتمل
الطريق الى اركين البري الحدود السودانيه
المصريه طريق بري عرضه 80 مترا على بعد
850 كيلو مترا من العاصمه الخرطوم شمالا
خطه تصطدم بتحديات امنيه كبيره خلال نقل
المواطنين الامريكيين من السودان الى مصر
طريق بري اخر وصولا الى ميناء بورتسودان
البوابه الشرقيه للسودان تبعد عن العاصمه
الخرطوم مسافه
675 كيلومترا نشرت امريكا سفونا فيها
كبديل اخر لاجلاء مواطنيها عبر البحر
الاحمر تضع امريكا خططا بديله قيد الدراسه
لنقل 16,000 امريكي في السودان وسط معركه
تتعقد ساعه بعد اخرى وهدى تتوالى لم يكتب
لاي منها الصمود غذاء السالم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات